[Music]
thursday edition pft ot where we talk
about things that maybe we had a chance
to talk about during pft live maybe we
didn't but it gives us more space
without worrying about breaks we can
talk as long as we want although usually
it's about i don't know 15 20 minutes
i'm going to jump right into it chris
sims the colts it's looking like they
will not have andrew luck for week one
it doesn't take much expertise to read
the tea leaves if frank reich wants to
name a starter after the third preseason
game if andrew luck's not going to play
in the preseason jacoby brissette is the
winner he'll start week one can the
colts win game or games if necessary
without andrew luck yes they can now uh
do i feel as confident certainly i do
not no andrew luck is special when he is
healthy i think we recognize that we saw
that last year we saw that prior to the
shoulder injury and all that those years
where teams that i don't think were
really playoff caliber football teams
that he got there because he has that
clutch gene i mean he's almost he's like
can't miss tv in the fourth quarter uh
you know whether they're winning or
losing you know they're one of those
teams and he's one of those quarterbacks
oh they're down by 17 to start the
fourth i bet you that game gets close
when it's all said and done and it
almost never fails that way so that's
where he gives me tremendous confidence
is those games where the team is not
playing its best football he is special
enough to overcome that we don't know
that about jacoby brissette yet that's
where it's a little different but i do
know that he is a starting caliber nfl
quarterback and there's some talent
around him so are they as good
no but i don't think they fall off earth
with jacoby per set
you know frank reich was recently
talking about andrew luck and he tried
to compare luck to like a video game if
you're playing it every once in a while
there's this high value target that
flashes and do you see it and do you hit
it and that's what andrew luck does that
there's an opportunity that pops up he
sees it and he goes for it and that's
what sets him apart i still think they
can put together game plans that will
allow them to be competitive i think
they're much better than they were when
jacoby bessette started 15 games in 2017
and brissett's in better position
because that time he was thrust in
through a labor day weekend trade with
the patriots he didn't have a chance to
really learn things and he still did
okay for himself now he's going to have
even more of a chance to be ready to go
and chris i just think at some level
frank wright has to like the idea that
that it's a test it's a challenge it
shows what he can do as a coach to try
to win without andrew luck and he's the
one candidate
two years ago for the job in
indianapolis who did not ask gm chris
ballard about andrew luck's health or
whether he's going to be good to go or
anything about andrew luck he wanted to
coach the indianapolis colts and that
means whoever it is that puts on that
helmet reich is the coach of that team
and and i i think that they're in great
they're in great hands with reich even
if luck can't play uh yeah and he proved
that to us right with the super bowl and
you know nick foles and all of those
things and uh you know to what you're
saying with frank reich not asking about
andrew like i do think that says a lot
yeah it shows that he's got confidence
uh to what you're saying in his his
offensive scheme his ability to game
plan for opponents and we saw that last
year i mean it got off to a rough start
and when he kind of found the rhythm of
what he wanted to do with the team i
mean every week they had a number of
what i call fu plays right to where it's
like they crack the defense code where
you're like holy cow this guy's wide
open that's unbelievable and uh he's
he's kind of good that way
see that's a new stat that we've
identified you've got the f up the play
defensively now we've got the fu plays
on the offensive side of the ball we got
to keep track i like it i like the fu
play thank you we have to we have to
keep track during the season for the
time and i will ask you if a guy's white
ass open as bruce aaron's would say
right is that an f you play okay
that's good stuff
all right uh the 49ers defense said fu
five straight times to jimmy garoppolo
we talked about this a little bit during
the show and this is amazing to me
five straight throws in practice were
intercepted and we didn't have a whole
lot of time to talk about during the
show i want to delve into the psychology
of this going forward because
jimmy garoppolo has this all unfold
among the very men he is expected to
lead
how much does it undermine him as a
leader when they've seen this holy crap
the guy threw five straight
interceptions who is he nathan peterman
i mean how do you come back from that if
you're jimmy garoppolo yes a valid
question um added to the fact that you
know it became delight this week that
you know also kyle shanahan was saying
the plays into jimmy garoppolo's ears
right he told peter king that to where
they always had to go into the huddle
talking together so he could spit it out
i don't think it's a crucial blow to his
leadership of the team
depending on this
how did he handle the five interceptions
yesterday you know you and i were not
there uh but hey guys are gonna be
they're certainly observing to to what
you're asking about they're looking at
jimmy garoppolo his mannerisms his body
language can they see it in his eyes in
the huddle that you know he's like a
deer in the headlights the next time
he's calling the plays yeah he's calling
the plays but you know the train's not
in the station right now because he's
flustered about oh gosh i've thrown two
three in a row it is astounding i will
say that i'm not like alarmed crazy
stuff can happen but i i truly mean this
i've never seen in any level
high school
college
nfl
any quarterback i've been around to
throw five straight interceptions in
practice you know even an adult like
myself who was overly aggressive in
practice and gruden was always scared of
my aggressiveness i can't remember
throwing more than two interceptions in
a practice let alone throwing two in a
row so that to me
you know garoppolo is a huge question
this year he is one of the
you know what do i want to say intrigues
of the year question marks of the year
of what we're going to get
and practice is the time to make those
mistakes it's the time to figure out how
far you can push it you take the chances
you know hey i can get away with this i
can't get away with that but yeah five
straight interceptions you make a great
point how does he deal with it did he go
into the locker room and slam his helmet
onto the ground does he act does he or
does he just shrug it off it's like hey
you know stuff happens we'll go get him
he was seven for 11 after that he threw
a touchdown right after that so how you
respond in those moments of adversity
goes a long way toward letting the men
you're supposed to lead know whether or
not they can count on you to deal with
adversity that will happen during games
i think it's an appropriate lesson
you're gonna have to shrug off an
interception during a game you're
probably not gonna have to shrug off
five in a row but you're gonna have to
shrug off one and how you handle that
moment of what the hell just happened in
practice goes a long way chris towards
showing your teammates and a coaching
staff yes how are you going to handle
those moments when they're going to
happen in games one last point there too
let's just not forget to you know and i
just as a quarterback i know this can
happen too
you know the the the look of those five
interceptions right were they all his
fault were they all just like in the
defender's chest did a receiver have the
ball and the ball popped in the air if
there was two or three of those kind of
mixed in there you know it won't be as
glaring or looked back it looked as
badly by the teammates so it's just
something i wanted to bring up sorry
well and and that's an excellent point
because there's a difference between a
horrible throw and just a crap happens
type of a throw and there are both of
those uh happen from time to time in the
nfl okay uh jimmy garoppolo throws five
interceptions on five throws on
wednesday the good news for matthew
stafford he's thrown no interceptions
all week because he hasn't practiced all
week and and this is a strange dynamic i
mean they're acting like the guy's 45.
he's just in his early 30s matt patricia
giving him the whole week off for rest
purposes this is kind of strange to me
they have a new offensive coordinator in
detroit shouldn't matthew stafford be
getting himself up to speed i it just it
invites all sorts of speculation and i
don't know what the basis for the
specular i mean i like what's the end
game here is he secretly injured are
they trying to get josh johnson ready
are they they planning to go with
somebody other than matthew stafford at
some point this is just a weird
situation to give a guy who is only 10
years into the nfl that much rest when
he's in the process of learning a new
offense yes i'm not buying it baloney
challenge flag all right i'm throwing
the challenge like at the detroit lions
okay
again
this is matt patricia and bob quinn they
just came from new england where tom
brady practiced all the time until he
was like 39 years old and then he got
some wednesdays off so it's not in their
dna to do this so that makes me question
it right off the bat let alone the
things you're saying it's year 10 and a
week a week off that they can say all
they want and this is why i wish they
would have injury reports in the
preseason because it's just not fair
it's not and they don't we don't know
but it to me it would look like it's
there's something ailing or annoying
whether it's tendinitis in the elbow or
the shoulder or something like that
there's got to be more to it than just
oh he's a 10-year vet and we got to
arrest him i'm not buying it
and and just so we're accurate it's six
dre six days without throwing not a week
but it's close enough yeah it's a long
time when you've got a new offense
you're trying to learn that's a long
time to go without throwing the football
and they're saying this was planned all
along but i agree with you
there's there's something's going on
here this is just one of those where
your instincts say
don't buy what they're telling you i
don't know what's really going on but it
feels like there's something more going
on whatever it is hey they're doing what
they have to do for the best interest of
the team right and you're right no
injury reports they don't have to tell
us if he's got tendinitis if he's got
some lingering problem uh but uh it it
just
it just cries out
yeah this is not normal right this is
not usual so we and we've seen cases
like this in the past where
what we're told and what's really going
on can often be two very different
things all right uh plenty of things
going on for antonio brown as it relates
to his legal docket he had a lawsuit
that he settled earlier this year for
throwing furniture off a 14-story
balcony in miami he settled that he has
another lawsuit that was filed by a
trainer who claims he was stiffed out of
his payment for a week of services in
april and now the sports chef
stefano tedeschi has sued antonio brown
for nearly forty thousand dollars for an
unpaid bill arising from pro bowl week
brown apparently rented a mansion in the
orlando area had this chef there and a
bunch of food bunch of parties bunch of
stuff bunch of ben hey easy way to to
afford something like that don't pay for
it nearly 40 000 that is owed brown has
been sued and and you know at a certain
point it can't be i've got a perfectly
good explanation for that i've got a
perfectly good defense for that at some
point the guy just doesn't pay his bills
and he forces people to jump through
hoops to get their bills paid and uh
that would be my guess with antonio
brown
yeah it seems like he you know certainly
a little bit of a knucklehead i mean
for lack of a better way to really put
it uh no he's awesome on the field and
we know that i mean he is amazing but
you know where this also leads me to
think okay just again being around the
nfl trying to read between the tea
leaves and all of that right
here's a guy who forced himself out of a
team
to get more money and we all heard the
rumors that we he didn't didn't think he
was going to get his next big contract
you know from the steelers that that
money was going to go to juju smith
shuster and things like that when i hear
little stories like this repetitively
like we're hearing that makes me think
that maybe he has money problems and i
don't know that i know i'm throwing out
accusations but that's just where my
mind went right away either way it's not
a good look and uh you can't be
stiffened people on on work they're
doing for you especially when you're a
star receiver in the nfl
well you're not throwing out accusations
let's be clear on that as your as your
as your unofficial counsel uh who is
trying to avoid getting you or me or
anyone else sued you're not saying that
he has money problems you're not
suggesting that he has money problems
you're just saying the circumstances
would put that in the realm of possible
explanations yes for not paying your
bills yes and there are people in all
walks of life who don't pay their bills
because there's an issue with having
enough money to pay the bills now he
only got a one million dollar signing
bonus from the oakland raiders earlier
this year most of that guaranteed money
is tied up in salary so
uh you know the and this all happened
back in
the january february time frame in and
around the pro bowl but uh
you know bottom line is
you either pay your bills or you don't
yeah and i i hate being in debt i hate
owing people money i pride myself on
paying my bills right away and if i
can't afford something i'm not gonna buy
it and i know if i'm buying something
that isn't cheap hey you gotta you gotta
pay the price on the back end so uh 38
000 plus allegedly not paid by antonio
brown and uh we'll see where that case
goes from here there's another case that
is still
pending in louisiana and there was a
little bit of a good news
uh ruling for the nfl on wednesday chris
the louisiana supreme court has decided
to press pause on the litigation that
has been filed over the rams saints nfc
championship game that means the
commissioner and three game officials
won't have to testify in deposition
settings next month it doesn't mean
they'll never have to but the louisiana
supreme court basically said look let's
just let's just put this all on hold
while we decide whether or not this case
should go forward good and and here's
here's what it boils down to chris i
want to get your thoughts on this as a
non-lawyer because as a lawyer i look at
this and i say i understand both sides
on the nfl side the argument is no
season ticket holder no spectator should
ever have any standing to ever question
in court the outcome of a sporting event
it's a bad precedent it opens pandora's
box it's just not a good thing even if
that that outcome
clearly is the result of a horrible
misapplication of the rules a spectator
a season ticket holder a gambler no one
other than the teams the people involved
should have any
standing to say anything about it
especially not in court here's the other
side of it though
and i've read the complaint that was
filed by the plaintiff in the lawsuit
who's also a lawyer in new orleans uh
and
and it suggests that the fix was in
that the nfl wanted the rams to be in
the super bowl because they're in la and
they want to promote the la market and
we've seen that the rams and the
chargers haven't really done as well as
we thought maybe they would when two nfl
teams went back to la but um if the if
the fix was in
i could see that being an exception to
the idea that
that fans and
season ticket holders and gamblers would
have no standing to do anything about it
because if the fix is in somebody's got
to have the ability to fight it to point
it out to bring the truth to light and
you know at what point do you give
someone a chance to prove that the fix
was in and that's what these depositions
are all about getting the evidence
aimed at at making an argument if an
argument can be made that uh the the
rams were hand-picked to go to the super
bowl i don't believe that yeah i i i
think that it's too hard to put the fix
in right and it's too hard to keep that
kind of a conspiracy quiet
but
i
as a matter of
of whether or not someone should have
the chance to try to prove that the fix
is in i am
if you got enough to go forward i you
know if you got something then why
shouldn't you have a chance to prove it
otherwise they would never
be proven there'd be no consequence
there'd be no downside at least not in a
civil court system if you don't let
season ticket holders gamblers and
others affected by that outcome
give them an opportunity to prove that
the fix was in yeah i i mean i agree
with a lot of what you're saying i don't
think it upholds in this
particular scenario okay and you know my
first thought and you've heard me say
this before you know again i just
you know i i hate to see you know
governments and state governments even
go down this passageway when we have a
lot of other big issues in every state
in our country right now but i know okay
okay there's plenty the government can
do a lot of things the government is
capable of i always i'm not so sure
about that always so let me tell you let
me tell you something
can i say something yeah i hate that
excuse me
i i hate that excuse because it is used
by the people who do not want to be held
accountable don't fall into that trap oh
aren't there better things to do than
this that's just why don't you leave me
alone let me go do the thing that i
shouldn't be doing and don't don't give
me a hassle and a hard time because you
should be curing polio or something like
that so that that's propaganda okay it's
unfortunate that it's stuck with you but
it's stuck with you anyway you know what
you're right though and i will i'll try
to change my outlook on that because i i
don't disagree with anything you just
said there and i'm coachable and i i get
it you're right because people do need
to be held accountable now this is where
i just will say this this is where it's
far-fetched to me okay nfl is killing it
all right it's the number one sport in
our country you can take the other three
sports and combine them and it's still
not the nfl so from that aspect there
wow they're gonna really risk it for the
la market and then one other thing that
just really jumps out to me the nfl
loves money and i know that that's the
case oh they're trying to boost the la
market and all that but
brady verse breeze belichick versus sean
payton might have broke the freaking
meter on ratings for the super bowl the
money would have gone through the roof
the anticipation of the game the game
certainly would have been better there
would have been so many great story
lines to go along with it that i don't
think the nfl would have put the fix in
to stop that just over the la market
which is questionable at best as a
sporting sporting city and when it comes
to football so to me that's just what
jumps out to me i don't think they would
risk that i mean brees versus brady was
the match up that was the the million
dollar oh gosh we can even charge more
for commercials now and i mean i just
think that that would have been the
ultimate matchup and you know yeah the
nfl made a mistake they messed up the
referees messed up they blew it and it
cost all of us and i get that and i get
why the saints fans are mad about it
and i agree with you completely chris
it's not that the fix was in it was
incompetence it was a horrible mistake
it was the fair of the nfl to have a
system in place
to fix the mistake but the fix wasn't in
i think from a from a legal theory
standpoint the idea that you do want to
create a slim opening for someone to
have a chance to take legal action if
they can prove that there was some sort
of orchestrated effort to turn football
into professional wrestling i get that
but i i don't believe that's the case
here i think they just blew it they
screwed it up and they've they've since
tried to fix that that flaw uh with an
overreaction that's how concerned they
are about a problem like that affecting
the outcome of future playoff games and
again with gambling here legalized
gambling spreading from state to state
they need to be concerned about doing
everything they can to get the calls
right and you can argue they did too
much i don't think the fix was in and uh
you know if the fix was in they they
waited until
the last minute of regulation to unleash
it like we would have seen it throughout
we would have seen a flag thrown for
that face mask of jared goff a few
minutes earlier exactly i think it's too
hard to fix a game and it's too hard to
keep it quiet uh i'm a firm believer
that the fix is never in and i know
plenty of fans think that that's their
way to justify the the fact that their
team lost but i don't think the the fix
is ever in the nfl no i i'm with you
there there's no way and you're right
there's too many mouths that have to
keep quiet and and everything else that
goes in too many variables i mean even
if the referees were trying to to fix a
football game gosh there's no guarantee
they could always do it if one team's
just having a horrible day or some
quarterback throws you know four
interceptions and two of them are pick
six it's harder you know said than done
that's for sure or easier said than done
well it's easier said than done to get
through some of these extra topics we
love talking football we love talking
with you chris take friday off you've
earned it no problem enjoy your time i
know you're working you're going to
south bend to get ready for the notre
dame season we'll look forward to that
look forward to doing more pft live next
monday and uh everybody check us out at
profotballtalk.com enjoy the games
tonight we'll have full reaction
tomorrow with big cat back in the studio
enjoy your thursday see you friday see
ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports